We have a new number one open-source
model. This is incredibly intelligent
and performant, and it's as good as the
top closed models out there. So, in this
video, I'm going to go over all the cool
things you can do with it, and I'm going
to show you how to use it. Plus, we're
going to go over its specs and
performance benchmarks. Let's jump right
in. Thanks to HubSpot for sponsoring
this video. The model is called GLM5 by
Z AI, and this is currently the best
open- source model you can use right
now. Best of all, it's free for you to
try out. So, simply go to Z.AI and
you'll see this chat interface just like
Gemini and ChatgPT. And then at the top
here, you should be able to access the
latest GLM5. Let's jump right in with
some demos. The really cool thing is it
also has this agent capability which can
help you do a really complex multi-step
task all autonomously. It can do web
search. It can use multiple tools at its
disposal to carry out a plan step by
step. Let me just show you a quick
example here. Let's make a fun
educational course on chemistry for kids
consisting of multiple lessons. Include
real images and interactive visual
exercises. And yes, we are going to
select agent and then press generate.
And here's what we get. Now, let's go
over the agent process first. It first
makes a to-do list. So, first it needs
to plan the chemistry course structure
with multiple kid-friendly lessons and
then generate engaging chemistry images
and then build out the lessons and
exercises, add interactive visual
exercises and then test and finalize the
application. So, it's planning out
everything and then proceeding to do all
these tasks. So, it has done the first
two, now it's moving on to this one. And
then it's building all these files in
the sandbox environment with all these
pages. And finally, it has done
everything and now it's testing for any
issues. And then afterwards, here is our
result. Now, if you don't use this agent
and you use the regular chat, then you
can only create like one page at a time.
But with the agent feature, it can
create multiple pages in a sandbox
environment. So, that's the advantage of
agent. Let's actually go through this.
I'm going to click on this button to
open this in a new tab. All right,
here's lesson one. And note that the
other lessons are locked. So, I need to
complete lesson one before I can move on
to the next lesson. Let's click on
start. And here's what lesson one looks
like. It even creates some really nice
images for us. And here, if I click on
like the image generation step, I
believe this is actually using ZI's own
image model called GLM image. So, here's
what I got from that. Next, let's click
on start exercise. And then we got to
complete this quiz. So, let me complete
this really quickly. You can see that
the quiz works. Plus, everything is very
interactive. The animations and the
visuals look beautiful. And check out
this really nice popup as well.
Everything is very welldesigned. Let's
click on next lesson. And then here's
the next lesson. We are going to learn
about atoms. And then here I can build
my own atoms. So let's build a hydrogen
atom. I believe I need to add one
neutron, one electron, and then one
proton. Let's see if that is correct.
Looks like there are zero neutrons. So
let's try again. Let's do this. All
right, perfect. Next atom. Let's build
helium. I believe it's two protons, two
electrons. As you can see, I suck at
chemistry. It's supposed to be 2, two,
and two. All right, next atom. Let's
build lithium. I have no idea what this
is, so I'm just going to click randomly.
I think it's 3, three, and three. Oh my
god. By the way, I failed chemistry in
high school. Anyways, we have completed
the lesson. So, let's move on to the
next lesson. Here we are going to learn
about elements. And as you can see, it
generated some nice images. However,
it's in Chinese and the periodic table
is kind of messed up. Let's start our
exercise. And then here, this is an
element matching game. So we need to
click on each element and then match the
correct symbol. So I'm just going to do
this really quickly. Oxygen is O, gold
is AU, carbon is C, and sodium is NA.
Very nice. Everything works and it's
designed very well, including the
transitions and animations. Let's move
on to the next lesson. Next, we are
going to learn about molecules and then
let's build water. So we need two
hydrogens and one oxygen, I believe. And
then let's click on check molecule. And
that is correct. Next molecule is salt.
And so on and so forth. Let me just
complete this really quickly. Now we're
going to learn about states of matter.
Start exercise. And now we need to
assign each item to the correct state.
So pencil would be solid. Rock is solid.
Juice would be liquid. You can see
everything works. Like it created this
entire course from just one prompt. I
didn't need to even prompt it further.
That's how good this is. And that's it.
All right. Right, moving on to the last
and final lesson. Now we have cool
chemical reactions. So here's the
lesson. Let's start exercise. Let's just
randomly guess. All right. And there you
go. And notice that after I completed
the course, it also marks my progress
here plus course completed at the top.
So your progress is tracked. Everything
is designed beautifully. And again, it
created all of this in just one prompt.
Now, of course, you can prompt it
further to add even more information and
more courses. But now you can just
prompt this AI to create educational
content for your kids or yourself to
learn. This can be customized and
personalized to make you learn a lot
faster. All right, let me start a new
chat. And this time we are going to use
agent again. Now I've already gotten the
last version of GLM to code up an
Android OS. That was way too easy. So
this time let's actually test its
creativity. I wanted to develop an OS
for mobile that's even better than
Android or iOS. include eight apps on
the home screen. Explain what you
designed, how things work, and your
rationale behind it. Let's press
generate. And here's what we get. If we
turn on this agent feature, then it
first creates a to-do list. And then it
goes through each of these steps. So the
first step is to design and plan this
mobile OS concept with eight unique
apps. Then it's going to create the
page. Then it's going to implement
interactive app screens and smooth
animations. Then it's going to document
the rationale behind this. So first it
plans out the design and then it codes
everything up and then now it's working
on this enhance and polish UI with
additional features and after that's
done it's now documenting the design
rationale. So let's go through this
first. Here is what our mobile interface
looks like. And here it has the smart
summary at the top. Its rationale behind
that is notification badges create
anxiety. Instead we should just have a
smart summary which gives us an
intelligent overview instead of all
those notifications. And then let's
check out each of these apps. So we have
Pulse, which basically tracks our health
like this. Very cool. And then here it
says it combines Apple Health and Fitbit
into one dashboard. Why it's better?
It's because Android or iOS health apps
are fragmented. Pulse gives a unified
health narrative. This includes like
heart rate, sleep, weekly activity, etc.
And then we also have this canvas
feature. This is for drawing stuff.
Okay. And then we have Nexus. So this is
like your chatbot that lives inside your
phone. Let's see if this actually works.
So let's type in something like what's
my schedule today. All right, so this is
just a dummy interface. It doesn't work.
But here it says Nexus is your AI
assistant. Kind of like Siri or Google
Assistant. But unlike those two, Nexus
can act across all apps with full
context. So it's kind of like what Apple
promised but never actually did. And
then we also have this flow feature.
This is like unified communications. So,
this groups all messages in one place,
including SMS, email, calls, and
socials. So, I actually really like this
idea. I hate having to switch between
different platforms and apps and
websites to see my communications from
different people. But flow just unifies
everything together, my email, my DMs,
my SMS, etc. And then we also have
vault, which is privacy and security.
So, let's click on this. And here's what
we get. So here it says iOS privacy is
good but vault makes it visual and
actionable. And then we have horizon
which is a smart context engine. So this
has like today's weather and then the
events that are scheduled today and then
smart suggestions. So it's kind of like
your agenda for today which again I
would actually find very useful. And
then we also have this mirror one which
is for digital well-being. So you can
also turn on this focus mode to pause
notifications. This tracks your usage
for today and how much time you spent on
each app. And then we also have this
bridge one which allows you to connect
seamlessly to other devices. So it's
kind of like AirDrop or iCloud. Very
cool. So that was the overall design.
And of course I can prompt this further
to add more features, but overall this
is a pretty good design and I do like
the rationale. Let me know in the
comments what you think. All right. Now
those were two examples of agents. Now
let's just use the regular chat. So this
is supposed to be faster. You can use
this if the task doesn't require like
multiple steps or really long thinking.
So here let's test its ability to
generate accurate physics and lighting.
So we are going to develop a real-time
simulation of two metallic spheres
suspended above a street scene. Allow
adjustable parameters such as
reflectivity, roughness, and other
material properties of the sphere. Put
everything in a standalone HTML file.
Make sure it loads efficiently on a
regular browser. Let's press generate.
All right. So, here's what it gave me at
first, but you can see this background
is fake. It's still pretty cool how it's
able to just code up this city night
scene using basic shapes like this. But
that's not what I want. So, here I asked
it to use a real background that's
publicly available. And afterwards,
here's what I got. But you can see that
I specifically asked it to generate two
spheres to see if the sphere would
reflect in each other, which it did not.
So I had to prompt it to make sure the
spheres reflect in each other. And then
afterwards, here is my final result. So
let me click on this button to expand
this full width. All right, here's what
we get. Let's play with sphere a. So
let's play with the settings. Let's
decrease metaleness. So this is what
happens. Very nice. And then let's play
with roughness. So this is what happens.
So that also works. And then let's play
with clear coat. That also works. Very
nice. And then we can also play with
clear coat roughness which does
something like this. Very nice. And then
what does I do? I have no idea what I
does. And then let's test out
reflectivity. Reflectivity also works.
Very nice. And then down here we can
actually select some presets. So let's
turn this into gold. And here's what we
get. Notice that as I change this to
yellow, its reflection on the other
sphere is also changed. Very nice. And
then let's change this to chrome. That
also works. copper, titanium, glass, and
then obsidian. Now, instead of this
street scene, I can also change this to
other backgrounds. So, let's try sunset.
It has a very nice loading screen like
this. And here's my result. Very nice.
And then let's try the other sphere to
make sure it works as well. So, let's
play with the metalness. So, that also
works. And then roughness. That also
works. Very nice. Clear coat. That also
works. And then clear coat roughness
also works again for iOS.
And then reflectivity also works. Very
cool. And then let's change this to
something like red. And you can see the
color is also applied to its reflection
over here. So everything works in just
three prompts. Very nice. All right. Now
GLM5 is multimodal. So you can even
input different types of documents for
it to analyze and output in different
formats. For example, let's write you
are a senior Wall Street analyst. From
these earnings reports, make a
consolidated spreadsheet of multiple
tabs with financials, charts, growth
forecasts, and recommendations. And then
I'm going to upload these Q4 earnings
reports from Google, Nvidia, and Amazon.
And then I'm going to turn on this agent
mode because I think this will require
multiple steps. Let's press generate.
All right. And here's what we get. Now,
since this is kind of squashed in this
side window, I'm going to download the
spreadsheet and open it on my computer.
So, first it gives us a nice executive
summary. I did check that all the
numbers are correct. And then here is a
financials tab like I specified with a
ton of different key metrics as you can
see here. And then here are some charts.
Here is the revenue and margin
comparison, etc., etc. Note that
everything is editable. I can move these
charts around. I can change the numbers
because this is well an Excel
spreadsheet. And then here is some
growth projections and forecast. And
then finally here are some
recommendations with price target,
upside potential, risk level, etc. It
also gives us the bull case and bare
case for each company. It even does like
valuation metrics comparison, SWAT
analysis. This is really good. And then
for Alphabet, it does recommend strong
buy. Note that this was like Q4 of 2024.
And indeed, since that time, Google has
gone up an insane amount. So anyways,
you can easily just input any PDFs and
get it to analyze it and convert that
into like a document or a spreadsheet or
a PowerPoint presentation or anything
else. This is a super flexible tool that
works with different types of files. Or
instead of getting it to analyze
financials, let's get it to actually
create a stock chart viewer. So let's
write create a stock price chart
visualizer with data from the attached
file. And I'm going to attach this file
from Yahoo Finance. These are the prices
of Apple throughout all these years. And
then allow me to set different ways to
visualize like line chart and
candlesticks. Allow me to select a past
date and replay it. Add, moving average,
RSI, and other indicators. And this is
pretty simple, so I'm just going to use
chat and then press send. All right,
here's what I got. Now, this is quite
compact. So, let me expand this in a new
tab. And let's play around with this.
Let's see if the line chart works. So,
that works. Candlestick also works. And
then here's the moving average. It even
includes like the 5, 10, 20, and 60-day
moving averages as you can see here.
Very nice. And then for exponential
moving average, this is also included.
Very nice. And then we also have
Ballinger bands. Very nice. And then RSI
is at the bottom here. This also looks
very nice. And then let's try to replay
this. So let's just use the default
start date and then press play. So as
you can see it is indeed playing from
that date. Very nice. And then I can
pause this. I can skip to the next day
like this. This is very interactive and
everything just works. AI agents used to
sound like science fiction. But in 2026
this has already become a reality. If
you have been hearing about AI agents
everywhere, but you're not sure what
they really are, how they work, or where
to even start, this playbook is exactly
what you need. It's called AI Agents
Unleashed Playbook for 2026 Success by
HubSpot. This guide breaks down what AI
agents really are beyond the hype. Not
just chat bots, but systems that can
think, plan, use tools, and run
multi-step workflows on your behalf. One
of the most useful parts is how it
clearly explains the difference between
chat bots and true agents. A chatbot
answers questions, an agent takes a goal
and delivers a result, like pulling
analytics data, drafting content, and
scheduling it automatically. The
playbook also walks through the state of
AI agents in 2026, where they already
excel today, and where human oversight
still matters. It shows why the real
power isn't replacement, but
partnership. You'll get concrete real
world use cases across content
generation, lead genen, customer
support, and internal operations,
especially for creators, solo founders,
and small teams. There's also a super
practical section on how to get started,
including how to identify low precision
tasks that are perfect for automation,
how to avoid overengineering agents too
early, and how to scale responsibly with
human oversight. They even cover the
most common mistakes people make like
overautomating too fast and exactly how
to avoid them. My favorite part is the
future focused section on how AI agents
are changing careers. Instead of doing
all the work yourself, the winning skill
in 2026 is becoming an agent
orchestrator. Directing AI systems while
you focus on judgment, creativity, and
strategy. You can read the full guide
completely for free using the link in
the description below. This resource was
made by HubSpot, the sponsor of this
video. All right. Now, next, because
this is multimodal, I'm going to upload
this image and see if it can create a 3D
animated scene from that. Use a single
HTML file. Let's press generate. All
right. So, here's what it gave me from
just one prompt. This is pretty good.
However, it decided to turn this into
nighttime for some reason. And then the
time up here, you can see it is like
turning from dawn to morning to midday,
but it's not actually changing the
lighting. So, that's something we need
to fix. But, as you can see, the cherry
blossoms and the pigota is not bad for
just one prompt, especially if you
compare this to the other
state-of-the-art models. Now,
interestingly, it decided to give me
everything in Chinese, even though my
prompt is completely in English. But
anyways, next I just added allow me to
change the time of day and make sure the
lighting actually works. So here's what
I got from that. Here is noon. Let's
change this to dawn. Very nice. So dawn
looks like this. And then I can adjust
this all the way until dusk and night.
And here is what we get. Very cool. And
I can move this around. Everything
works. It's not bad. Now, of course, the
pigota can look better. I can prompt it
further to add more details to the
pigota and also fix the top that is
disconnected up here. But I mean with
just two prompts, this is already very
good. All right, here's a fun example.
Let's see if it can actually compose
music. Now the first step is I need to
get it to create a piano roll interface
before I can get it to create a song. So
let's write create a piano roll
interface where I can drag and drop
notes on the timeline, add play, pause,
and other settings. Put everything in a
standalone HTML file. make sure it loads
efficiently on a regular web browser.
Let's press run. And here's what I got
from just one prompt. So, let me expand
this. And here's the piano roll. It
already added something by default. So,
let's play this.
[music]
Now, I can add additional notes here.
So, for example, let's add a few more
notes like this just as an example. And
then let's press play.
>> [music]
>> All right, so that works. But that's not
the point of this prompt. I want to see
if it can actually compose something by
itself. So next, I asked it to by
default show a powerful expressive 32
bar piano opus rich in complexity
capturing the final performance of a
master pianist. Let's see what it gives
us. And so afterwards, let's expand this
and see what it composed. [music]
[music]
>> [music]
>> All right, I'm just going to pause it
there. It doesn't sound too good. I
guess there's a ton of dissonance in the
track. It's not very harmonious. It
sounds like the dude is dying or
something. But let me know in the
comments below. Does this sound like a
powerful expressive piano opus capturing
the final performance of a master
pianist? Maybe this is actually good,
but it's just a lot deeper than I can
perceive. All right, here's another fun
example. Let's get it to create infinite
terrain maps using this plland simplex
noise. Users can share seeds to recreate
worlds. Toggle biomes, rivers,
mountains, and climate simulation. Let's
press generate and see what it gives us.
How cool is that? It just built this in
one prompt. I didn't need to prompt it
further. But here we have this infinite
map which we can play around with. So
here's just one seed. I can shuffle the
seed for it to generate a completely
different map. In fact, let me full
screen this first and let's play with
the settings. So here is one seed
number. I can set this to another random
seed and it would generate a completely
different map for me. Very cool. And
then let's adjust these toggles. So
let's turn off biomes. And here's what
we get. Let's turn off rivers. So, that
removes the rivers. Let's turn off the
mountains, which gives us that. And then
let's turn off climate. Not sure what
that does. So, I can probably prompt it
further to fix some of those issues, but
there you go. Here's an infinite map
creator that it made with just one
prompt. I can also use my mouse to zoom
in and out. Really cool. All right.
Next, let's also see if it can code up
some games. So, I'm going to get it to
create a 2D platformer game similar to
Super Mario. Make it look amazing. put
everything in a standalone HTML file.
Use publicly available assets, models,
and effects for the game. All right, so
it gave me this in just one prompt. I
actually don't even need to prompt it
further. And it added some really cool
features like this parallax background,
a dynamic sky gradient, procedurally
drawn character, plus particle effects
everywhere, smooth physics, two enemy
types, bouncing slimes, and flying bats
with wing animations, stomping
mechanics. I'll try to stomp on some
enemies when I play the game. So you can
see what this looks like. It even has
coin collection. It has a live system.
Infinite procedurally generated levels.
Wow. And it did all of this in just one
prompt. Okay, I didn't need to prompt it
further. So let's press on start game.
And here is my character with a cape.
Let's collect some coins. So the coin
collection works. And let's try to stomp
a character. So that also works. Let me
try to stomp some additional characters.
All right. Now next, let me try to jump
across this. So that also works. Now, if
I fall down, then I die and I lose a
life up here. There you go. Here is a 2D
platformer game which it just created in
one prompt. It includes multiple enemies
and infinite levels and everything
works. It keeps track of my lives. It
keeps track of the coins that I get. And
you know, even the background looks
pretty cool with this parallax effect.
Now, of course, I can prompt it further
to make the visuals even better to add
even more complexity to the game. But as
you can see from just one prompt, this
is already extremely good. This is
definitely one of the best models out
there in terms of agentic coding. Now,
instead of coding up cool stuff, this
can also help you with everyday tasks
and help you do deep research. So, for
example, let's give it this pretty
tricky medical prompt. Analyze the
molecular pathology of distrophen loss
in this molecular distrophe. Compare
therapies and evaluate long-term
functional outcomes from recent trials.
include nice tables and charts. And
here's what I got just from the chat
feature. So, it's very concise and
straightforward. Here is the molecular
pathology of this distroofen loss. Here
is the mechanism of everything. And then
here, it gives me a nice table of the
molecular consequences of this. It's
jam-packed with information. Next, it
gives me a comparative analysis of
therapies. And it even gave me this nice
flowchart which I can move around. And
then here's a comparison of all these
therapeutic modalities. It's really
thorough and jam-packed with
information. All right. And then
afterwards, here is long-term functional
outcomes. And then here is some more
data on some recent trials. Now, here's
another chart, but it looks like it
couldn't really code this up, so it just
decided to give me this chart, but in
raw text format, like this, which is
pretty cute. And then afterwards, it
gives me a summary of the outcomes of
all these recent trials. And then here's
a conclusion and future outlook. So,
it's also great at handling like science
and research related prompts as I'll
show you in a second from some
benchmarks. All right, final prompt.
This is just a fun trick prompt that
even trips up GPT. So, the prompt is I
need to wash my car. The nearest car
wash is 50 m from my house. Should I
just walk or drive there? And you know,
the funny thing is for chat GPT, it
actually told me to just walk there.
But, of course, the answer is I should
drive there because I need to wash the
damn car. But if I plug this into GLM5,
it was able to answer this correctly. It
says, "You should drive. The primary
goal is to wash the car. If you walk,
your car remains dirty in the driveway.
The car needs to be present to be
washed." So, that sums up some of my
quick tests with GLM5. As you can see,
this is an incredibly powerful and
capable model, and GLM has always been
my long-term favorite open- source
model. It's the one with the least
amount of errors. It usually just gets
everything correct in one or two
prompts. Next, let's go over its specs.
So, compared to the previous version,
GLM 4.5, GLM5 is actually a lot larger.
So, they increased the parameter count
from 355 to 744 billion parameters. So,
it's more than double the size. Now,
this is a mixture of experts models. So,
think of it as like a team of agents
working together at once. So when you
use it at any given time only 40 billion
parameters of these 744 billion
parameters are actually active and used.
So even though it's huge this is very
efficient. Now here it says they also
integrated this deepseek sparse
attention mechanism which was introduced
by deepseek and this lets it handle
really long prompts or documents without
needing as much computing power. Note
that the context window of GLM5 is
200,000 tokens. And this is like how
much information you can fit into your
prompt at once. 200,000 tokens is
roughly 150,000 words. Note that this is
the same context window as Claude Opus,
but this isn't the largest context
window out there. For example, Gemini 3
Pro has a 1 million token context
window. That means you can fit like
around 700,000 words into the prompt.
whereas GLM5 you can only fit like
150,000 words. Now, similar to Deepseek,
in addition to just training the models,
they've also added reinforcement
learning after this initial training
stage to get even better. Right? This is
basically learning from feedback to
improve its answers even more. However,
this reinforcement learning training is
quite inefficient. So, they also
developed a new system called Slime,
which basically speeds up reinforcement
learning training so it can improve
faster. so it can improve even faster.
Next, let's move on to its performance
benchmarks. So, here are some of the top
the most widely used benchmarks to rank
LLMs. And as you can see, GLM5, which is
the blue bar, is pretty much on par with
the top closed models out there. So,
humanity's last exam tests NEI's ability
to answer questions from some really
obscure scientific domains. These are
questions that most people don't know
the answer to, but as you can see, GLM5
even outperforms the leading closed
models out there. And then for SWEBench,
verified and multilingual, and terminal
bench, this basically test an AI's
ability to do a gentic coding. And as
you can see, GLM5 performs pretty much
on par with the top closed models out
there. And then here are some other
benchmarks for your reference. And then
browse comp is a benchmark that tests an
AI's ability to browse the web. And as
you can see, it outperforms the rest of
the models by quite a large margin. Here
we're comparing GLM5 head-to-head with
Claude Opus 4.5. And as you can see, for
most of these tasks, it's pretty much on
par with Claude Opus. Here's another
really cool benchmark called Vending
Bench 2. This is a benchmark used to
measure how effectively an AI model can
run in a simulated vending machine
business over a long period of time, up
to a year. So, this tests how good an AI
is at like running and operating a
business. It's given a balance, usually
like $500, and it needs to make as much
money as possible by performing all the
tasks required to run a business,
including like managing inventory,
ordering products, pricing strategy,
financial management, and of course, a
ton of other business problem solving
and decision-making. But, as you can
see, GLM5 even beats GBT, and it's
almost as good as Opus and Gemini 3 Pro.
And then here are some other benchmarks
for your reference. If you compare this
with the other leading open- source
models out there, including Kim K 2.5,
it's not even close. Like for most of
these benchmarks, GLM5 just performs way
better than Kim K 2.5, which by the way
only came out, I think like 2 weeks ago.
So I hope you can feel the acceleration.
Now those are just some of their
self-reported benchmarks. Let's look at
how this ranks in a third-party
leaderboard called Artificial Analysis.
So here you can see that indeed GLM is
currently the top open- source model out
there beating Kim K 2.5 and it's almost
as good as GPT 5.2 extra high as well as
Claude Opus 4.6. It's only like three
points away and it even beats Gemini 3
Pro high. So this is incredibly
impressive for an open- source model.
Now what I find is even more attractive
is the price. So with that level of
intelligence, it's actually insanely
cheap. Notice that Gemini is over three
times more expensive. Same with GPT. Gro
4 is even more expensive and Claude Opus
will just make you broke. So, I mean, in
terms of efficiency, GLM5 is the best
bang for your buck. And you know, this
is actually the best feature of GLM5
that I haven't heard anyone talk about
yet. It has by far the lowest
hallucination rate out of all the models
out there. So, here is the artificial
analysis omniscience hallucination rate.
And the lower the score, the better.
This means it hallucinates less. So, as
you can see, GLM5 out of all these
models has by far the lowest
hallucination rate. You can see like GPT
5.2 or Claude Opus is like more than
double this amount, which means it
hallucinates a lot more. Now, note that
this 34% means it got 34% of the answers
wrong on this benchmark. This doesn't
mean that it hallucinates 34% of the
time when you use it. So I think this is
actually the most powerful feature of
GLM5. This is especially useful if you
need to deal with very factually
accurate information like for law or
medical research. All right, finally
let's go over where you can use this.
Like I said, GLM5 is currently available
for you to try for free on ZI's chat
platform. And of course, they've already
open sourced this. So if you click on
hugging face, the models are already
out. However, note that this is like 1.5
terb in size. So, no, you're not going
to be able to run this on consumer
hardware, but it's mostly for
enterprises who really care about data
security and privacy and running an AI
locally on prim. This is especially
important because if you use any closed
proprietary model like GPT or claude or
whatever, all your chats are sent to
their servers. So, they potentially have
access to all your information. And
that's the power of open source is that
you can run it privately and locally.
Now if you can run this and this is of
interest to you then on their GitHub it
contains all the instructions on how to
download and run this locally. Now in
addition to this you can also just
subscribe to use GLM through their own
API and this is actually insanely cheap.
The cheapest plan is like only 27 bucks
per quarter. So that's like just 9 bucks
a month which is way cheaper than
Claude. Now note that for API usage
currently they are rolling this out
gradually to coding plan subscribers but
afterwards you would be able to use this
in all these coding agents including
claude code. For those of you who aren't
aware you don't actually need to use
claude in claude code. You can switch to
a much cheaper model and then this also
supports openclaw as well which is like
an agent that runs 24/7 on your
computer. If you're not familiar with
openclaw see this video. Anyways, that
sums up my review on GLM5. This is
currently my favorite open- source
model. It's just so good at coding
things with the least amount of errors.
Plus, it has the lowest hallucination
rate out of all the other models. And I
personally use GLM in Claude Code and
OpenClaw myself. Anyways, let me know
what you think of this. If you've had a
chance to play around with GLM5
yourself, what's the vibe that you got
from it so far? As always, I will be on
the lookout for the top AI news and
tools to share with you. So, if you
enjoyed this video, remember to like,
share, subscribe, and stay tuned for
more content. Also, there's just so much
happening in the world of AI every week.
I can't possibly cover everything on my
YouTube channel. So, to really stay
uptodate with all that's going on in AI,
be sure to subscribe to my free weekly
newsletter. The link to that will be in
the description below. Thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one.